excavation tranché paris se transforme
un peu partout des champions et est
implantée les grands travaux de paris et
de la région parisienne sont en cours
certains d'entre eux seront bientôt
achevés et en ce qui concerne paris
monsieur herzog directeur technique des
services de la voirie parisienne fait le
point monsieur roch peut-on faire un
bilan des grands travaux en cours à
paris et bien si vous voulez je ne
parlerai pas des 300 chantiers qui
perturbe un petit peu nos rues pour
assurer le développement du gaz de
l'électricité mais essentiellement des
grands travaux qui se tiennent surtout
sur le boulevard périphérique à l'est à
l'ouest
au passage souterrain de l'étoile et en
divers points pour des parcs de
stationnement si nous commençons par
l'est
nous avons près de 8 km 2 boulevard
périphérique qui vont pouvoir être livré
à la circulation au début du mois de
mars prochain
ce qui d'un seul coup améliorera
grandement les conditions de circulation
à 13 sorties de paris et donnera en même
temps la continuité à quatre fils dans
les deux sens le long
en somme de ce boulevard cette zone
comporte des ouvrages tellement
exceptionnel qu'il est difficile de
choisir parmi eux pour parler de
certains sites ont tout de même le pont
masséna au dessus de la sncf
ce pont à près de 500 mètres de long
7000 tonnes d'acier le poids de la tour
eiffel en dehors de cet ouvrage
exceptionnel
mentionnons aussi l'échangeur de bercy
qui comporte une dizaine d ouvrages
d'art enchevêtrés qui comporte 22
bretelle de liaison dans tous les sens
et qui va même en importance devancé
l'échangeur de la porte de la chapelle à
l'ouest de paris effectivement les
travaux dans le bois de boulogne ont été
entrepris en la zone la plus délicate
c'est à dire sous le
supérieur la plus délicate parce que
c'était la plus longue il a fallu
assécher le lac et transformer
complètement les abords du champ de
courses d'auteuil
mais si ces travaux se poursuivent ils
sont aussi complété par des travaux
situés entre cette zone du bois de
boulogne et la scène c'est à dire
essentiellement d'abord la porte de
saint cloud alors la porte de saint
cloud une partie importante des travaux
pourra se terminer au printemps prochain
et déjà commencera à porter certaines
améliorations
puis les travaux se poursuivent par la
reprise en sous oeuvre les installations
du parc des princes ce qui est un
travail absolument considérable et qui
comporte d'ailleurs ensuite la
transformation même du parc des princes
aussi enfin on inaugurera bientôt le
commencement de travaux dans l'échangeur
de la porte d'auteuil elle même ou pour
assurer la continuité des circulations
dans tout ce secteur alors à l'intérieur
de paris je citerai d'abord le passage
souterrain de la place de l'étoile qui
apportera localement un soulagement
considérable à la circulation des champs
elysées en permettant à toutes ces
voitures de franchir la place et
d'évacuer l'avenue des champs elysées
beaucoup plus rapidement qu actuellement
et puis une douzaine de parking plus
gigantesque les uns que les autres sont
actuellement en cours de construction
dans le sous sol d'un certain nombre de
places ou des revenus en ce qui concerne
la région parisienne de chantier
important d'attirer notre attention
celui ci est implantée à meudon en
bordure de la forêt il constitue le
premier élément de la bretelle qui
reliera le petit clamart à paris quant à
roissy en france où est en train de
naître
le nouvel aérodrome de la région
parisienne les travaux sont en bonne
voie de finition
bientôt les premiers avions pourront
tester les pistes du troisième aéroport
de paris